à 8 ans j'ai eu droit à vivre une
expérience terrible de vivre la
séparation d'un père et d'une mère
successivement de vivre l'abandon de
devoir m'occuper d'une sort de moi même
de nourrir
vous savez une fois qu'on avait vidé les
placards de la cuisine on avait plus
vraiment une solution
donc on aller mendier en suisse et oui
cela peut arriver peut arriver en suisse
peut arriver de vivre en or des radars
sociaux des institutions et ce fut pour
moi
au regard de toute expérience qu'on peut
faire chacun différents degrés ma
première découverte de l'interdépendance
l'interdépendance sociologique entre un
frère et une soeur qui devait faire
corps qui devait être fort alors je me
suis construit de façon innée je suis
allé chercher des réponses dans les
mathématiques dans les sciences et
technologies
j'ai trouvé dans un monde de contrôle
dans la gestion du risque opérationnel
des réponses des satisfactions sont à
valoriser ça m'a réconforté
mais vous savez la vie elle vous
rattrape toujours
la crise financière de 2007 fut pour moi
seconde vague d'ébranlement et de
chamboulement sur mon système de
croyances sur ce que j'avais construit
pour y arriver pour être fort pour être
dans les rails avec les éléments qu'on
me donnait et puis cette crise
financière a été tellement puissante que
j'ai remis les compteurs à zéro je me
suis dit qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre
dans ce système défaillant général qui
construit le moteur de développement
économique qui nous est tous à nous
développer aujourd'hui
alors j'ai fait une petite expérience
j'ai pris un j'ai fait un voyage dans le
parc teman negara en malaisie quarante
mille kilomètres carré de jungle
tropicale
je vais essayer de pas trop vous à se
mettre des chiffres ce soir mais bon ça
c'est naturel revient au galop
je suis un peu désolé davance 130
millions d'années luxuriant une faune et
une flore incroyable j'ai passé neuf
jours de connexion avec la nature et ce
fut pour moi une deuxième expérience
forte d'interdépendance avec la chose la
plus simple que l'on a c'est notre
capital naturel mais il fallait que je
l'expérimentent il fallait que je
connecte les choses ensemble
heureusement j'avais pris un guide un
donc j'ai pu en sortir et donc est là ce
soit avec vous évidemment ça a été pour
moi le début d'un autre processus de
recherche pour comprendre comprendre
comment cette grande machine infernale
qui est le monde de l'entreprise
l'économie fonctionne à comment on
pouvait aujourd'hui avoir un système qui
dysfonctionnent qui est déséquilibré
alors je vous laisse
parce que vous êtes sûrement pas tous
des experts en statistiques ni en
économie on peut être que oui et tant
mieux mais il n'y a pas besoin de tout
ça vous comprenez bien qu'il ya un
problème qui est un déséquilibre contre
seulement 5% que cette croissance qui
est générée s'adresse à 60% des plus
pauvres et donc dans cette recherche
d'informations systémique complexe je
suis tombé ensuite sur une autre étude
une étude peu connu et peut-être que si
nous sommes certains d'entre vous l'ont
vu j'aimerais bien qu'ils lèvent la main
parce qu'elle est vraiment peu connu et
les munich
elle a été menée par trois chercheurs
des systèmes complexes à zurich
l'école l'institut fédéral de
technologie de zurich en 2011 et ces
trois chercheurs ont mis en relation
quelque chose qui m'a paru comme une
révélation plus que ça comme une
solution
alors ils ont pris sur une base de 40 3
millions d'entreprises de référence et
ils ont analysé les dépendances les
liens entre ces acteurs de l'économie
mondiale et puis sont arrivés à détecter
un super nous allions sur ces 43
millions il avait un super mario 2318
entreprises qui à elles seules génère 20
% du chiffre d'affaires mondial qui à
elle seule influence 60% du chiffre
d'affaires mondial
non le second noyau vous voyez en jaune
alors je vous laisse faire des
interprétations de ce déséquilibre
je vous laisse imaginer toutes les
théories que vous voulez moi ça fait
pour moi un message extrêmement positif
que j'avais plus à devoir m'attaquer à
125 millions d'entreprises dans le monde
ni à 43 millions il fallait qu'on
adresse les choses sur un groupe
toutefois très puissant très gros et
qu'un nombreux qui était de 1318
entreprises qui représentent des
multinationales des acteurs de
l'investissement à ce genre de choses
pour leur adresser une mission
complémentaire que seulement celle de
faire une génération de profits et elles
font déjà beaucoup beaucoup d'entre
elles sont déjà mis en mouvement et dieu
merci on n'aurait pas les progrès que
l'on a vécu ces dernières décennies
sinon plus largement
est ce que certains d'entre vous entendu
parler de l'accord de paris levait
jusque là moi comme ça j'ai un peu à un
logement
on est dans une salle qui a poliment je
faisais cela dernièrement et j'ai été
étrangement surpris de voir cinq main
levée dans une salle qui était un peu
plus compliquer salle ce soir
d'accord de paris ses 193 pays qui se
sont réunis et qu'ils ont validé un
agenda à l'horizon 2030
on l'appelle aussi l'agenda 2030 pour
ceux qui le connaissent la suisse l'a
finie aussi la suisse travaille aussi
sur un agenda à 2030
ces dix sept objectifs de développement
durable en fait sont une excellente
nouvelle
aussi on a un cap on a une feuille de
route nous suffit maintenant tous
ensemble d'imaginer comment on peut y
contribuer
et je vous parlais des acteurs de
l'économie mais là je vous parle d'un
agenda humain je vous parle de vous de
moi de nous tous ou dans nos
comportements dans nos actions dans nos
choix on peut contribuer à cela et
l'urgence est là l'urgence je les
analyse et techniquement je l' ai vu je
l'expérimenté je la constate tous les
jours elle est là on ne lutte plus
contre le réchauffement climatique
on va devoir s'adapter pragmatiquement
et trouver des solutions pertinentes
pour faire avec le réchauffement
climatique
c'est une donnée qui bouleverse 30 ans
de mouvement de lutte et de réflexion il
faut y aller et c'est positif on a un
cap on a une feuille de route alors une
autre chose que j'aime à partager avec
vous ce soir c'est que j'ai eu la chance
de participer grandement à la fédération
d'un mouvement à la canalisation
d'acteurs d'entrepreneurs
d'investisseurs d'entreprises parce que
dans les entreprises il ya des
entrepreneurs
il ya des investisseurs et des humains à
travers une déclaration une déclaration
d'interdépendance aujourd'hui ces
entrepreneurs ont tous dit dans notre
feuille de route
dans ce cadre qu on veut prendre on va
mettre le principe d'interdépendance au
centre prend en compte les besoins et
l'impact que l'on a pour les générations
futures
prendre en compte l'impact qu'on a sur
la société au sens large et sur notre
engagement pour soutenir cette société
est évidemment celui sur l'environnement
ce grand principe évidemment doit
s'accompagner de choses rigoureuse et ce
mouvement débit corp
ce mouvement des entreprises certifiées
big up by corporation and benefit
corporacion
quand vous l'avez compris est un nom
anglo-saxon
ils sont des entreprises un impact ou
avec une mission d'impact y au delà
d'avoir signé ces principes
d'interdépendance cette déclaration qui
vous me direz tout le monde peut le
faire
elles ont décidé de faire revoir leurs
pratiques de faire vérifier leur
performance sociétale environnementale
de faire acte de transparence et de
redevabilité par rapport à leur secteur
d'activité par rapport à leur modèle
d'affaires
elles ont aussi décidé d'inscrire dans
leurs statuts juridiques
cet engagement ces principes d'avoir un
impact positif matériel sur la société
l'environnement de rendre redevables son
management et ses actionnaires là dessus
elle là on commence à parler là ça
commence à devenir intéressant pour
parler de changement systémique pour
parler d'amplification de bruit
d'accélération et tout dans leur secteur
aujourd'hui démontre qu'il ya une autre
façon de faire qu'un autre est possible
que l'on peut associer business et
agendas humain ce mouvement aujourd'hui
est composé est reconnu à travers des
choses qui je suis d'accord n'est pas
super sexy n'est pas forcément des
standards oui des normes pour savoir
comment est ce qu'on retient de libre
des choses comment est-ce qu'on
progresse comment est-ce qu'on
s'améliore et ça sert à quoi
qui est-ce qui en a besoin de ces
reconnaissances un peu technique des
consommateurs pour les identifier ces
bonnes entreprises pour identifier ces
bonnes entreprises qui font ces bons
produits qui les font dans le respect et
dans cette orientation de cette feuille
de route des investisseurs pour
sélectionner des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui reçoivent un accueil
favorable du grand public
vous savez ces fameux milenio je vois
qu'on en a quelques-uns au premier rang
ça me réjouit comme je vois qu'on a pas
d'être interdite génération l'indre
actuellement le premier rang mais ça les
points à quelque chose qu'ils ont un
honneur c'est de faire du bien dans
oracle de consommation du moins c'est ce
que disent beaucoup de recherches et de
statistiques aujourd'hui
pour cela il faut leur permettre de les
reconnaître pour cela ça donne une envie
aux investisseurs d'aller donner de la
capacité à ces entreprises il faut aussi
adressé sa au niveau des décideurs
politiques pour qu'ils créent des
encouragements des incitations pour
cette entreprise qui réponde à un agenda
qui est autre que simplement économiques
s'y intéressent aussi des enjeux de
société
les enjeux environnementaux et fait
évidemment les entreprises pour que dans
leur sphère sphère d'influencé puisse
déployer ces bonnes pratiques et donc
augmenter leurs capacités à de
bienveillance si je le dis comme ça
aujourd'hui on vous parle de 2600
entreprises dans un mouvement mouvement
qui grandit au fur et à mesure et qui
peut être extrêmement réjouissant cette
lecture que je voulais partager c'est
une lecture qui est partagé par beaucoup
de monde par beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
par beaucoup d'employés et forcément par
beaucoup d'humains sur cette planète qui
donne du temps qui donne de l'énergie à
faire ce qui est bien ce qui est juste
dans leurs capacités évidemment dans
leur sphère d influence et alors là
quand vous envoyez à certains grands
noms qui étaient déjà débit corp avant
qu'on existe évidemment si vous pensez à
nos amis qui font des habits d'outdoor
je n'ai pas le droit de dire les noms
des démarques
ce n'est pas du tout mon intention mais
voilà ce sont ces débits corde depuis le
temps sont si hauts yvon chouinard très
engagé de la première heure s'est
retrouvé là dedans pourquoi il s'est dit
ce mouvement là il va me permettre de
protéger ma mission parce qu'un jour je
vais quitter l'entreprise soit pour
faire autre chose soit parce que la vie
en a décidé ainsi
et là on retrouve aussi des acteurs du
cru
j'aime me dire que vous connaissez tous
ont décidé de mettre cet objectif
d'avoir un modèle d'affaires qui tente
de changer le monde c'est pas beau ça de
se réveiller le matin de se dire mon
modèle d'affaires mon entreprise bas
elle participe à changer le monde
elles ont toutes cet objectif partagé
aujourd'hui elle couve 160 secteurs
d'industrie
c'est merveilleux c'est très complexe
parce qu'il faut mesurer vérifier ces
entreprises mais il faut aussi partager
des belles histoires pour inspirer les
autres
une mission qui comme vous l'imaginez
vous donne la patate
ça me donne un espoir sur ce qu'on est
capable de faire et la suisse sur ce
compte agenda elle a plein de choses à
faire vous avez plein de choses à faire
des académiques nos institutions
politiques nos entreprises
au delà d'un mouvement d'une
certification et d'un label et de toutes
ces principes et ces valeurs nous sommes
en train de réfléchir et nous
réfléchissons depuis un plusieurs années
sur le positionnement systémique du
changement de l'économie comment cela la
législation non enregistrement d'une
entreprise commence toujours par la
sélection d'un statut juridique
aujourd'hui nous le faisons adapté bon
an mal an mais aux états unis depuis
2006 en italie depuis 2015 des formes
juridiques existent pour quand un
entrepreneur une entreprise soit
s'inscrire dans cette direction dans ce
cas puisque sélectionnés y avoir
structurellement juridiquement ces
réponses dans ses statuts dans sa forme
juridique et donc dans le mode de
déploiement de son pouvoir
fiduciaire c'est un énorme étape et
c'est une énorme étapes dont je me
réjouis peut ensuite parce que le 22
août dernier
nous avons une réponse du parlement une
interpellation sur l'opportunité de
créer cette forme juridique en suisse
et alors comme vous le savez en suisse
timidement on a dit dans mes bykov c'est
très bien continuer comme ça c'est la
direction à prendre
mais plus tard
plus tard mon pays je les aime beaucoup
mon pays seront pas compte que plus tard
c'est demain et qu'il faut accélérer
alors pour pas finir sur une note
négative
il faut vraiment se fédérer il faut que
ça vienne collectivement de tous les
milieux de tous les secteurs de toutes
les régions que c'est ce cap cette
direction là qu'il faut prendre
l'exemple du mouvement des big up en est
un
il ya d'autres mouvements qui existe le
social business vous avez peut-être déjà
entendu ou l'entrepreneuriat social en
bon français le capitalisme conscient
l'économie inclusive quelqu'un a déjà
entendu le terme économie inclusive dans
la salle
ok demain 3 4 où j'ai travaillé un petit
peu personnellement à faire connaître ça
mais ça m'étonne pas assez normal
l'économie inclusive elle repose sur
cinq piliers extrêmement basique un
public et la solidarité donc de
développer une activité économique sur
le pilier de la solidarité sur la
participative it et la rendre accessible
à tous l'inclusion d'intégration la
rendre stable
forcément avec un cadre juridique la
route durable en prenant en compte des
limites de l'environnement et donc cck
premiers piliers sont réalisés avant on
peut y ajouter le cinquième cas la
croissance
il ya pas de problème ça fonctionne bien
parce qu'on lui a mis dans l'adn les
éléments structurels qui lui donne une
orientation alors au delà de cette
opportunité historique il faut quand
même toujours garder en tête une chose
c'est que je lisais dans la nzz encore
il ya quelques jours trois économistes
que je n'aimerais pas je me souviens pas
tous leur nom et ma prononciation
suffisamment est terrible mais qui
indiquait que pour eux il y avait tous
les éléments étaient réunis pour qu'on
se retrouve dans une crise comme en 2007
économique sérieux et d'instituts
reconnu je le dit leur document il j'en
conviens qu'il ya effectivement il ya
une lecture qu'on peut donner
donc il faut garder ça en tête on n'est
pas à l'abri la contagion d'un système
comme vous l'avez vu avec ses 1300 18
entreprises ses dépendances qu'elles ont
entre elles peut-être une machine
infernale
quand elle est contagieuse et quand elle
se met à
nos mouvements et donc il faut aussi
garder en tête d'autres désastres
environnementaux je pense que vous avez
tous entendu parler des typhons au japon
en ce moment j'ai pris le dernier qui
malheureusement est apparue et je plains
tous et tous ses habitants de cette
région c'est un désastre de voir tous et
tout ce peuple dans des conditions
pareilles
la pauvreté mondiale la démographie sont
des enjeux aussi importants qu'il faut
garder en tête qu'ils vont accélérer
tous ces changements là et sans compter
le changement climatique qui comme on
aime bien dire on ne lutte plus contre
mais on va devoir s'adapter
alors voilà ça un peu anxiogène c'est un
peu un peu lourd tout ça mais ça c'est
notre cap on est une opportunité de
changer les choses
on a un agenda qui courent 2030 allez ça
pour être 2035 toute façon les dommages
en environnement ils sont faits le
réchauffement climatique va continuer d
degré vont monter on va devoir s'adapter
mais il faut mettre un agenda pour que
dans les quinze ans à venir on ait réglé
ses enjeux majeurs qu'on est amené la
dignité au plus grand nombre et
conseille évidemment innover trouver de
nouvelles solutions pour régénérer notre
environnement et pas simplement diminuer
notre impact dessus et on peut le faire
aujourd'hui je sais que dans cette salle
dans les discours que j'ai pu entendre
ce soir avant des solutions il y en a
beaucoup
ce qu'il manque c'est une voix
collective et c'est ça qui est en fait
notre grande opportunité historique
c'est d'agir de façon collective
aujourd'hui pour demain j'aimerais finir
ce soir sur une phrase d'un artiste et
d'un architecte qui qui me tient à coeur
particulièrement depuis des années qui
est un artiste autrichien friedrich
intervint soeur et qui dit lorsque sur
un homme rêve
ce n'est qu'à 20 av mais si beaucoup
d'hommes rêvent ensemble
c'est le début d'une nouvelle réalité
[Applaudissements]